ان هناك صراع اخر لواشنطن لكن مع جاره
بيكين اي كوريا الشماليه وذلك حول تجاربها
النوويه والتي كان اخرها اطلاقا ما تجسس
عسكري لمراقبه الانشطه الامريكيه العسكريه
في المنطقه حيث تكثف واشنطن من تواجدها مع
اليابان وكوريا الجنوبيه لمواجهه ما
يصفونه باستفزازات
ورغم فشل عمليه الاطلاق الا ان واشنطن
بانت هذه التجربه وقالت
استخدمت التكنولوجيا صواريخ البالستيه
المحظوره ما يزيد التوترات بمنطقه شبه
الجزيره الكوريه ويهدد بزعزعه الامن في
المنطقه وخارجها
ومع ذلك اتهمت الشقيقه القويه للزعيم
الكوريه الشمالي كيم جون كون الولايات
المتحده بالتصرف مثل العصابات لانتقادها
فشل بلادها في عمليه الاطلاق وبررت فشل
عمليه الاطلاق بان الصاروخ فقد قوه الدفع
بعد مرحله انفصال هو تحطم في المياه قباله
الساحل الغربي لشبه الجزيره الكوريه
وتعهدت باعاده التجربه بشكل ناجح قريبا
كما قالت كيميو جونغ ان جهود بلادها
لامتلاك قدرات استطلاع في الفضاء هي
ممارسه مشروعه لحقها السيادي